good evening everybody and welcome to
this southeast area planning committee
meeting
good evening councillor helm
on the 18th of august 2021
i've got some feedback coming from
somewhere i don't know if that is that
better yeah yeah good
my name is councillor vanessa bell and i
am the chairman of this committee
before we commence the business of the
meeting there are a few housekeeping
issues to run through
members to set up for the meeting has
been designated to mitigate for covid
therefore can i ask all present to work
to the protocols agreed at council on
29th of april 2021
in the interest of member and officer
safety we are streaming this meeting
live as well as recording and by being
present in the meeting you are giving
your consent to being recorded
members and officers during each item
please put your hands up raise or raise
your paddles i think you've got paddles
have you put your hands up there you
have
wave your paddle or otherwise indicate
how i somewhere where i can see you that
you wish to speak
i will then invite you at the
appropriate time
when invited to speak please remove your
mask turn on your microphone and speak
clearly please reference a page or
paragraph number when referring to the
agenda papers keep your contributions as
clear and concise as possible and ensure
your microphones remain off when not
speaking
and finally can i draw your attention to
the notices on the agenda paper
regarding the different levels within
the chamber and advise that the fire
exit door is behind the top table
members i i'd also like to take this
opportunity to introduce alex taylor who
was a new see senior planning officer
um
senior specialist coordinator
development management that's there yeah
that's a mouthful alex isn't it really
can you hear me
yes
yeah can do
so um i don't know if perhaps members
would like to just go around and
introduce themselves to mr taylor
we do have to use the microphones when
speaking at all times because otherwise
the recording won't pick it up so okay
let's um so just switch it on when when
you're talking and then off immediately
afterwards so perhaps if we could start
counsellor stamp with you please
um yeah i'm cancer stamp and the leader
of the council welcome i think you know
us anyway don't you i've had dealings
with you
thank you yes
do you know everyone does everyone know
mr sailor
no we'll continue to go around then so
council boys
uh councillor voice member for all thorn
brian beer member for southminster
councillor schemes member for burnham
crouch
counselor hell member from mayland
councillor channel member from mainland
politics winning late mountains and i
went to the football club my brains
i have done that the other way around
cancer channel so don't worry you are
definitely not the only one thank you
members and thank you mr taylor
so moving on to item two apologies for
absence burn and i have the apologies
please
thank you chairman we've received
apologies from councillors passenger
duik and hull
thank you thank you
items three minutes it is recommended
that the minutes of the meeting held on
the 21st of july 2021 found on pages
seven to eight are approved as a true
and accurate record and
i so move members do i have a secondary
agreement that's the second agreement
the year marvelous thank you very much i
think that was a great blessing
thank you
item four declarations of interest to
disclose the existence and nature of any
disclosable peculiar interests other
petunia interests or non-pecuniary
interests relating to items of business
on the agenda having regard to
paragraphs six to eight inclusive of the
code of conduct for members
members are reminded that they are also
required to disclose any such interests
as soon as they become aware should the
need arise i think we're going to have
some declarations council helm not in
your interest
mrs patton councillor white is a
councillor i know her
and nipsl's farm was owned by a
grandfather several years ago so i'm
very intimate with mipsal's farm thank
you thank you councillor helm
councillor stamp
uh thank you chairman i'm a member of
essex county council which have been
consulted on this application i also
know councillor white i don't know
councillor white's husband
but i would like to say that some of us
has received correspondence to do with
the application i don't think it pauses
any it poses any complications or
alleged pre-determination at all because
i certainly for one haven't made my mind
up on this application and we will
debate it fully um as the meeting goes
on thank you thank you council stamp
councillor chandler
um
i'll speak with this one actually madame
gem uh yes just to declare the same
reasons as councillor helm
i'm a you know councillor white or
rather mrs white who is a councillor i'm
aware of her husband mr patton i've met
him previously i too received
correspondence but i see it that was
perfectly in order because any residents
can write to members as we know and i
get emails letters from everyone madam
chambers so there's nothing else
awarding that whatsoever
thank you anyone else i have also
received correspondence from mr payton
and i'll just
repeat what cancer stamp and council
channel have said in relation to that so
thank you
okay
that does bring us on to item five
which is twenty one zero zero zero six
two eight forward slash full land north
of rivers lee nipples chase mayland
so this is found on pages 9 to 26 there
is a members update in relation to this
application that's been circulated
so can i head over to these please to
present the report thank you
thank you
chairman and so as stated please note
the members update which confirms that
no suitable rams legal agreement has
been submitted as well as clarification
on some of the comments received by the
applicant
this application seeks planning
permission for a two-bedroom bungalow
and the planning statement makes
reference to the fact that this is a
live work unit however this is not
considered to be the case in planning
terms
it's noted that the dwelling includes a
study however this isn't unusual for a
dwelling a live work unit would have to
consist of both a clearly defined
residential and employment use
the dwelling is also proposed to be a
self-build dwelling
which again has been noted in the report
the planning statement considers that
the applicant is on the self-build
register and hasn't been offered a plot
of land
however it's not the responsibility of
the council to offer land the onus is on
the applicant to attain one of the plots
available
there is a total of 48 plots in the
district 24 self-built permissions and
24 sites granted outline permission that
would be suitable for self-filled
dwellings
and there are only 11 people on the
self-build register
and therefore there are more than enough
plots available
it's also noted that this application
follows two previous applications which
were withdrawn prior to determination
the application in 2017 proposed a
dwelling in a similar location
and this application was withdrawn prior
to the committee meeting however
concerns were raised in the report
regarding the impact of a dwelling in
this location on the rural character of
the area
the application from may this year also
proposed a dwelling on the site
and again it was withdrawn prior to the
committee meeting however concerns were
raised in the report due to the impact
on the character of the area and the
inaccessibility and sustainability of
the site
so this is the location plan showing the
access taken from
lipsaw's chase here so this is where
the maid and lit part of the road of
knipsaws chase ends and this is sort of
an unmade
part of the road and then the site
here
this is the proposed block plans showing
the access road along nipsals chase and
the proposed dwelling including the
driveway taken from the existing access
into the site
so this is just a wider view of mainland
to give context of the um location of
the site and some of the points that
have been raised in the report
so this is the application site here
um the three red dots are the three
surrounding historic applications that
have been referenced in the report in
section 5.1
and so one dwelling was approved here in
2017.
this site was considered to be an
accessible location as it connects to
the main settlement by um a sort of lit
made footpath
150 dwellings were
refused and the appeal dismissed on this
field here
um
so although it was refused this
application proposed a new footpath
connecting to the maid part of nipshal's
chase so it wasn't refused on
accessibility grounds
and then the other application was for
50 dwellings in this field and again it
was refused but that also proposed a
footpath connecting to the
main settlement of mainland
the three yellow dots are showing where
the facilities are in mainland so to the
west of the application site
so this is a convenience store
um salon medical center and school
so these are not within walking distance
of the site along a
made suitable
footpath with lighting
and so this
red line here is a public right of way
however again as i've said um
this isn't a made footpath and there's
no lighting along here either so it's
not a usable or practical method of
accessing the facilities and bus stops
that are in mainland
and then the two smaller red dots
here
and over here
are the two bus stops referenced in
section 5.1 of the report
and from looking at the timetables
published online there is no regular
seven day a week bus service that would
be a suitable alternative
to using the private car which is
contrary to the guidance set out in the
mppf and the ldp
which promotes the use of alternative
modes of transport
so this is the proposed floor plan
so there's two bedrooms on this side a
home office
main living area and the garage here
and the elevation plans
and some photographs of this site
showing the view north and south along
the maid road of nipsl's chase
and then just one picture here of the
nichols chase leading up to the
application site
these photos are showing the um
entrance to the public right of way that
leads west into mainland and then the
view along that
public right of way
and then some of the views um
along nipsal's chase to where the
application site is located
some photographs of some of the existing
neighbouring dwellings and then the open
fields to the east
and some views of the entrance to the
application site
and views within the site so the
dwelling would
be located off this access here
overall due to the inaccessible and
unsustainable location of the site and
the impacts on the character of the
rural area the proposal is considered to
be contrary to the guidance contained
within the mp mppf and the ldp
furthermore an incomplete legal
agreement has been submitted in relation
to rams
the application is therefore recommended
for refusal thank you german thank you
very much louise so uh i do believe we
have the applicant mr payton
who would like to speak so uh mr payton
you have
two minutes when the clock starts
so are you ready
um can you remain seated i'm sorry could
you remain seated i'm sorry thank you
but do pop your microphone on
i think i think it is
it is
i can't see the red light from here
thank you when you're ready mr bite okay
dear members malden does not have a
five-year housing land supply and
sustainable housing should be granted
mailland is one of only four sustainable
villages in the entire district
a 10-minute walk from doctors a nicer
store pharmacy post office hairdressers
and schools
we change our application to address
reasons for refusal
it is a fact that the site now starts
within the development boundary of
mailand
mdc note this but then attempt to
dismiss it
it was acceptable for a large
development but not our two bed bungalow
the village access site
is now for on public made roads
the unmade road is inside the site so
not a valid reason for refusal
if approved it will create 7.3 new
habitat
no effect on the countryside as it is
screened by a thick hedge with houses
either side and uses the existing drive
we have been on a self build register
since 2017
and the government is giving over 400
million pounds to start a self-build
revolution
policy h3 states the council has an
obligation to ensure that housing needs
for all of the people in the district
are considered it does not state that it
must only be for large developments
i'm upset that specialist needs of my
wife are not considered relevant by the
mgc
despite offering full medical records
the rams agreement can be conditioned
this is a sustainable village and
location
the site starts within the village
boundary it will improve nature and
habitat please grant permission for a
sustainable home in line with the nppf
thank you excellent timing mr payton
thank you
okay members
over to you
as i said previously my grandfather used
to earn nixle's farm and
mainland was my playground
the orchard
from bramley way
through past their site was all owned by
mr blake who used to walk around in
black willie boots
blue overalls in a trilby hat
so i remember that quite well and we
used to go regularly scrumping in the
orchard
um
the the nipples chase itself is owned by
the white family
there's only a small particle near the
bottom which isn't owned by them so
they're in the whole road
um
dust carts must go down there
morrison's tesco's deliveries all go
down there
and i used to cycle over maryland from
one side of the road mill road right the
way through just like that easily
and what's wrong with the torch nowadays
don't we use torches
why do we have to have street lights if
you go to burnham
stoney hills for instance
that's been won several times on the
peel
and where's the street lights there
and then we say we must be reliant on
the car but why do we have
two parking spaces per house or more
depending on the size of the house
so that's reliant on the car isn't it
and what's
what's the reason why we can't use the
shanks as pony in other words their feet
we can walk anywhere
people are encouraged to walk to get
exercise
so i don't agree with the recommendation
and i would
recommend we go against the council's
recommendation and approve this site
so is that a proposal yes it's a
proposal do i have a seconder for that
proposal oh mr lee
firstly obviously before a proposal or
after proposals made we need clarity on
the point and as we know we shouldn't be
moving it until uh the end of the debate
because
okay uh it would be it would appear you
know that
until the whole debate is people
shouldn't be moving so that's obviously
that's gonna be focused
yeah
a point of order on what mr lee has just
said
um
i i don't know whether this is a
a ruling for the planning committee only
but we debate motions
that are proposed and seconded
because
otherwise
there is
really no
legitimate debate until there is a
motion on the table so with while i take
advice from
the uh from
the committee clark please
if you will through your chairman um
yeah this is the advice that paz have
provided us um as through the restaurant
obviously that's the process we have
been taking recently as chairman we do
questions then at the debate and final
because members are discussing a
planning application and not actually
discussing the officer's recommendation
so there's a there's a difference
in the protocol compared to a normal
item in a normal committee so that's
just the suggested protocol if members
don't have to do it but that's just our
suggested protocol thank you thank you
that that makes sense to me mr lee um
cancer skates
uh yes well of course my mind is
completely open on this
it's difficult to decide i do have
concern about development in
in rural areas i see that two
larger developments in the same area
have been turned down and one wonders
that if one is allowed then more will be
allowed and i am concerned that we are a
rural area and we must do everything we
can to protect it of course the
hypocrisy of that situation and some
would view it comes into play when a
large development is allowed not here
but in other rural areas and we refuse
the smaller ones but i take the point
that others have made
that if you allow a lot of smaller ones
that can create as many problems as
allowing one larger one my feeling is at
the moment anyway that we should do what
we can
to protect the rural character that
we've got
thank you
thank you i mean i
don't want to but councillor helm has
already drawn a text so counselor how
could you pop your microphone sorry
thank you council helm has already drawn
ascension to stony hills and you know we
we all know what's happened up at stoney
hills and
we really don't want to see that
happening in the district again in my
opinion so
one must be mindful cancer channel face
thank you uh madam chairman i just want
to ask one question at this juncture
there may be others if i may when
perhaps the debate goes on
um reference was made by the planning
officer
and so to one of the red dots and yes
the 150
on the right hand side of nipsl's chase
and we've heard um
that in that instance it appeared that
the
issue of accessibility didn't appear to
come into the equation
but on this incident it does i'm i'm
having a bit of difficulty
trying to ascertain what is diff what
the difference is between 150 what seem
to have the accessibility and this
application
and doesn't bearing in mind i believe
this application has changed from the
last one i wasn't at the last meeting
but i think it was withdrawn anyway but
i think that report so i'd just like to
get that confusion out my mind because i
find that a bit duplicitous i'm not
criticizing officers but on one hand 150
we say okay okay it went down that
appeal but
one individual dwelling we're saying
it's not okay i'd just like to
understand that better please can you
help us out louise with that thank you
through you chairman um
because that application was for 150
dwellings and they proposed um a new row
a new access and footpath to join
straight onto the maid part of nixle's
chase um so
sort of joining this
um area
down here
and so it would have bypassed the unmade
um
part of the road
for uh sort of pedestrian access
so residents could have
directly walked
sort of along here to you know down to
that bus stop or or into mainland
and because of the scale of the
development it's reasonable to
ensure that's carried out but for one
dwelling it wouldn't be reasonable to
require upgrading the whole road just
for one dwelling under this application
thank you cancer challenge does that
answer your
question well i've heard the answer yes
thank you
thank you but any other members wish to
cancel the boys please
um uh
thank you chairman um yes i just want to
um sort of pick up on one or two things
that
council helm
has indicated and that is the issue
perhaps of sustainability and i think i
agree with him that that
that this is probably a sustainable
area
that it
that it's in
but i accept that there are other
um concerns
um
for instance
leaving the other concerns aside for the
moment
we have
in lattingham for instance we have
in the middle of the village an
unadopted
road
that lighting is not maintained by the
highway authority
um
so they have to walk about in the dark
in the middle of a village middle of
um
what has now been determined a large
village i believe
um all of a sudden it's half as big
again as a thorn
whereas always used to be smaller than
author
um
so i i have some sympathy for the
application i do believe it's in a
sustainable area
but i accept
that the other
reasons
for refusal perhaps are not easily so
easily pushed aside thank you jim thank
you council voice any other members wish
to cancel the hell again
um last time we had the apple store and
i did mention that
the apple star couldn't be seen from
anywhere unless you stood on a seawall
somewhere or really high up because
they've got high hedges and you can't
see anything in the site from outside so
how can it be an eyesore in the
countryside
and there's wildlife there i mean i have
live in an industrial state
we have a rabbit coming to our patio
frequently foxes and everything run
around so there's no deterrent against
animals or anything like that so they
can thrive
um the other condition regarding the
rams
that can be sorted out by condition the
republican
of plenty of commission that they pay
this so there's no problem there i don't
know what the other one was now
we've got sustainability we've got the
sight line
help me out
if you can
chairman um yeah sustainability impacts
on the character of the area and rams
well it can't impact the character
because you can't see it from outside
unless you go inside and there's lovely
oak trees and all that be protected by
the council
well by condition sir and there's a
little orchard there and all sorts there
so that's that sorted it doesn't it
doesn't impact on the countryside full
stop
thank you and it's sustainable as well
thank you thank you
i could ask you tell your microphone oh
sorry please cancel channel
um thank you madam jim um i've heard
what council helms had to say about the
apple store and i think that's
[Music]
in situ on the site
currently
but um i think also um approval was also
given for barn come stables
and um
i don't know it was a question sort of
area as well
i believe that was quite significant
structure as well so
i'm just trying to get that in my mind
we've got approval given for stables
etc as i suppose without any dwelling
that might operate nearby i mean the
orchard doesn't run that
so one could say why was stables in a
barn allowed was it seen as agricultural
or what you know and didn't need to have
a dwelling nearby
and then the apple store so there are
two structures coming onto that
site already which are deemed to be okay
so again i'm trying to work out why
a dwelling house is seen to be not in
keeping
and unsustainable where i might argue an
apple store yes okay it would come from
the apples on the site
but then also the
the barn and stuff there that's going to
have traffic and things going to it i
would imagine and
the apple store as well so i'm just
trying to get that in my mind two
structures being allowed but not the
residential dwelling
the difference is really between those
three to say two could be approved or
whatever they were approved whatever
reasons
and um the dwelling is not acceptable
i will go to i'm afraid i'm going to put
you on the spot in a moment but i
believe the equestrian
facilities were considered appropriate
for a rural location if i recall but if
you can help me out there is a tool
chairman and that's correct um the sort
of storage barn and
stables are accepted forms of
development in the countryside
and a dwelling isn't um that's you know
sort of what the mppf and our local
policies um say thank you thank you
thank you
any of them cancer stamp i'm sorry i
couldn't see you behind the many layers
of yeah thank you thank you i have put
my paddle up a couple of times
now it's absolutely fine because it sits
more um i actually agree with what many
of the other members of members have
already said madam chair
yes i understand it's in the countryside
it's a two-bedroom bungalow
the amount of
meetings and
applications i've heard and officers say
that we need smaller accommodation in
the area
i think our ldp identifies that anyway
i agree with councillor helm i don't
think it can be seen
and i think the mainland is actually a
growing village whether we like it or
not like many other villages and towns
in our district
it has got a doctors it has got many
facilities and believe me i know exactly
what they're like because i walk around
them when i delivered leaflets so i
helped deliver leaflets in that area um
so i've been driven around there and i
actually don't have a major problem and
i know that i could get into trouble for
that mr lee because he would turn around
and say cancer stamp you're going to say
to president but i don't actually
believe we are the sustainable argument
has been um discussed for the past
goodness knows how many years at this
southeast planning meeting and i've sat
there at the meetings when cancer dewic
and everybody has argued for the
sustainability argument and and i think
we should be actually supporting people
um with
disabilities it's private i don't want
to talk about if they're going to be
disabled but have got actual illnesses
and problems and i know i always get
talked down about this because i can't
help it i do believe that we should be
looking after people and planning for
the future i'm purposely not looking at
mr lee because i can feel him actually
staring at me
but i actually oh he's not oh good
um but um
i take on board what cancer skin said
about we don't want to uh attract
development outside in the countryside i
think we can see a lot of that that's
already taken place and i'm not saying
two rights make her wrong um but i
i'm still haven't decided but i don't
see it as being such a a massive problem
as what the recommendation is at this
stage thank you madam chair thank you i
will go to councillor skins please
yes sir just briefly i am concerned
about the president um
of course there have been bigger
presidents uh but i think if we get into
the habit of allowing single dwellings
in remote areas to occur
we're going to get a lot more of them
and we're not we're going to have a lot
of trouble uh controlling it
which
and and i
obviously have total sympathy with
anybody who has a an ill relative who
they for whom they're trying to cater
but has as has been explained to us as
committee members many times those
personal circumstances you can't take
them into account because you're talking
about the lifetime of the building not
the lifetime of the people and if you're
building to accommodate somebody um
who's unwell out of sympathy that does
not speak to the future of the building
so there is an issue there so again i'm
in two minds but those are the prime my
my primary concerns at the moment
thank you councillor shana please um
thank you talking about um on the
personal issues and of course i think
we're aware what various documents say
on that i do recall in all thorn and
that is an unsustainable location that's
been proven many times appeals
regardless of what it may have or not
have but i do recall and actually i'm
sure councillor boyce will
remember this being the world member for
such a long time smuggler's club ground
this council
refused an application
and actually it went to appeal and it
was won on appeal and it was allowed on
the personal it was said because of the
personal circumstances health issues of
the applicant at that time
now i think there was some form of
condition that's applied
in that case and i'm not i'm sure mr lee
can advise me on this but i do recall
that um
quite well actually and i perhaps can't
i don't want to put council voice in the
frame but i do recall it on smugglers
club ground because the parish were
against it this council was but on
appeal um we lost it and it was a case
that the um
health situation of the applicant
actually was a consideration in that
determination of that appeal i'm sure
i'm absolutely remembering it correctly
thank you that's very interesting and
i'd like to know more about that case
actually because i think it would be
helpful thank you i'm not going to put
mr lee on the spot right now and i'll
ask him though so
um
officers would anyone like to come back
on any of the points that have been
raised
yeah um
so i'll just sort of run through them
but can everyone hear me okay bye
absolutely okay it's a bit yeah
yeah
you're fine though
so
in terms of
the issue of the circumstance of the
individual i think we have to appreciate
that this
application would be granting consent
for a building which will almost
certainly help
outlive the needs of the individual
um so then we need to move on to
the circumstances of whether the scheme
would be acceptable
in terms of screening
we
we have to be careful because
much of the screening around the site is
not necessarily
that's going to remain there
indefinitely also so again we need to
consider
the impact in terms of permanence
it's clearly within the countryside
looking at the aerial photograph to me
you i think this building could
in time clearly become
quite visible and would have a
detrimental impact in that regard
in terms of sustainability indeed i'll
see precedent has been mentioned i think
what we need to consider are the
individual circumstances of the site
so
[Music]
for one thing we're aware that the road
is clearly unmade and unlit and it's not
particularly
would not be particularly appealing to
alternative forms of transport other
than a private car
um
and therefore is not very well linked to
the assessment and that is the
fundamental problem of
the sustainability arguments
um
i hope that answers some of the points
raised
thank you very much for that mr tyler
councillor helm did make a
make a point about you can put tpos on
trees which would mean that they aren't
going to be removed in the future but
i think
we also need to bear in mind that the
test for tpos is not in regard to
providing screening for building needs
to be screened
the test is whether it's of uh visual
amenity value so it's not inappropriate
there may be valuable trees there there
may be or there may not be but it's not
it's a misuse of the legislation
thank you um councillor channel and then
i believe councillor hamilton's big
hovering
just clarification if i'm a uh madam
chairman but bear in mind i referred to
smugglers and i would say that's quite
significant number of years ago but what
i just want to know is is the officer
saying there is no condition that can be
applied regarding the personal
circumstances
of the applicant um
to uh you know to save for the lifetime
or whatever
i i'd just like to have some
clarification if there is any
possibility that that is permissible i
think we did it with an annex in
mainland as well if i'm correct um and
annex being allowed somewhere um and
linked to um okay was on the same site
but it was linked to a drilling house so
it's just about this personal condition
could that be applied to overcome
perhaps some of the issues that have
been detailed within the report and i
think what members are raising tonight
thank you i'm going to go back to mr
taylor and then come to councillor helm
so if you could respond mr taylor please
sorry could you ask the question again
apologies
okay
chairman mr taylor didn't catch it
wasn't getting councillor chana to
repeat her question um
members need to obviously recall the six
tests in relation to the imposition of a
condition
and
um what
they are you know necessarily reasonable
precise enforceable relevant to the
permission and
reasonable on all other matters
we do have the powers to impose personal
permissions we do have rights to impose
temporary consent
and
that is quite a powerful gift and we
need to balance that and only use it
appropriately um councillor channel's
reference smugglers club and i don't
know the case off the cuff but my
assumption would be that that related to
attempt either a personal commission for
an existing structure to be used as a
permanent dwelling rather than as a
holiday accommodation that is very
significantly different to the
construction of a whole new dwelling and
similar things with an annex where you
require it to be used as an annex or as
ancillary accommodation so once the
personal permission or the individual or
anything is removed from that situation
it can revert back to another use
legitimately so in case of smugglers
club it would have probably gone back to
a holiday accommodation in relation to
an annex you know it's unlikely it was a
specific individual so they could use it
for an annex you but also any other
ancillary use such as a summer house or
a gymnasium or anything like that that
they wish so for those reasons
there is an acceptance about temp
permissions or personal permissions
things such as caravans or
uh
you know buildings that can be
structured can be removed players they
can have a temporary permission because
there isn't a permanent there's not an
unreasonable burden upon the applicant
in the future to remove that um
guidance is that you shouldn't look to
put a temporary permission on a
building i've and i would specifically
say you'd be unlikely to die advised
that you should be putting the temporary
permission
so in theory that needs to be demolished
for one of the better phrase on a whole
new dwelling because that just wouldn't
be proportionate to the structure and
the point of a personal permission would
be that if you would say that only the
applicants were able to live in it
when for whatever reason that ceased and
you know it could be for whatever
reasons you know the lottery could be
one tomorrow and they move off you'd be
left with a white elephant as in you'd
be left with a dwelling that has no
lawful use within the uh rural community
area and that's why your guidance would
be that you wouldn't be imposing that in
situations such as this you know and
that would be my advice chairman thank
you that's helpful thank you mr lee so
two council hell now please oh sorry
cancer stanford thank you thank you
councillor helm um
i think if you and if to drive around
our district you see many houses in the
middle of fields uh you only have to
drive around asheldon and deng etc and
you do see i can say many smaller
properties little bungalows in the
middle of a field that are that you
could class as being unsustainable
um and um
i still don't see
i personally don't see and have a major
issue with this one uh and i am to
apologize if i may vote against the
officer's recommendation but um i think
a small dwelling like that um is is okay
thank you
thank you i have to say i want to go to
councillor home they knew council voice
but i'd say i went and i had the
privilege of being a judge on the mould
and design awards panel today and i
travelled all around the dengue i know
councillor channel you've done that in
the past
and i didn't say indeed come across some
very unexpected dwellings in
extraordinarily remote places so yes we
do
have such
dwellings in the district so council
helm and council voice thank you very
much during the pandemic
we've all worked from home
be in a little room or whatever so the
the point about
live work is quite relevant
whatever
[Laughter]
so we've all worked from home all the
officers in this council have worked
from home so they've used a room in
their house
to work from home
it uses an office but have they got
plenty permission to use their house as
an office
thank you
just the point i wish to raise thank you
thank you
council voice
chairman um
i said that i thought it was sustainable
um the reasons for refusal one and two i
i'm quite happy that
that
we can comply
and overcome those
um which leaves the legal agreement
so can i ask that if the committee were
not to accept the officer's
recommendation
could
conditions
uh be applied
to
overcome the
reason three
thank you council voice officers
for you chairman uh it could be approved
subject to um suitable rounds mitigation
or a suitable legal agreement supplied
yeah thank you thank you
excellent
members
are we ready to go i think we've spoken
extensively about this i think
oh sorry mr taylor i think i missed uh
making one other point in the debate
which was to do with the rural
structures that have been granted in the
area i just wish to emphasize that
our policies do support
uh
buildings which are suited to rural
purposes
uh subject to all the usual sort of
tests but housing is of a fundamentally
different nature
and it does change the character of an
area
from
rural to suburban stroke urban
so
um
i think we need to be careful about
considering the argument of
there being rural buildings that have
been granted permission as setting a
precedent for a house in this location
thank you mr sailor okay
please sorry did you say cancer schemes
first i'll give you
yeah i totally take on board what mr
taylor said and what everybody else has
said but i think there's one and forgive
me i should know the road the one in
legend and opposite the tea rooms can
you remember that place that was um
approved is it a yellow brick house is
it that one
oh don't go there sorry i'll go there i
won't go there then chairman
um yeah it was that it yes it maybe was
one on appeal but it it was still
purposeful oh okay well i rest my case
i'm wrong i stand corrected
cancer schemes
i would say that we have to be careful
in
if we consider that there are houses
existing there was given planning
permission long before that are in
remote locations fact is the more houses
that are built in a rural location the
less rural that place becomes and i'm
really keen to protect the countryside
if we can that's my view
indeed so remembers i'm going to go to
if i oh no i'm not mr lee
do you chairman if that's okay obviously
i think um
i'll tell you
yeah um it's just a couple of points
that were raised just recently that's
not sure and in the world about 100 have
been covered so just as a general point
of principle um as members have heard me
say a thousand times you know the
starting point of determination of any
application is the local development
plan
the policies that we have clearly
channel dwellings new dwellings to
either strategic sites or within the
settlement boundaries so if we're ever
going to look to accept dwelling outside
of the seven boundaries or the treaty
sites which needs to be material
considerations that weigh in favor and
personal opinion all things like that as
we know members is not a material
consideration so you need to see what
the benefits or why the weight should
weigh in favor of this scheme against
other developments that would be outside
the segment boundary because each
application is material consideration
determined of another application and
classic example would be stony hills you
know an appeal decision that officers
nested weren't for my time but members
obviously probably weren't keen on a
couple of overturns by members and we've
ended up in the situation where we are
so
every decision does
have bearing on the future this site is
remote
in many terms in relation to access to a
good footpath
then therefore access to facilities um
the fact that the area is red brings it
down to the road
shouldn't should only be given
minimum weight because at the end of the
day the dwelling is where the dwelling
is and there's a requirement for the
future occupiers to access the site acro
through an unmade road um the distance
is not
insurmountable it's a noticeable
distance to that footpath along an
unmade road and
if members are going to say that is
acceptable that will be a consideration
in the termination of every application
is outside a certain boundary and future
across the district
if members consider that not being able
to clearly see a new dwelling in a rural
area
because they're hedging up that will be
a consideration for every application in
the future across the district um we are
in a time we haven't got a five year
hand supply so they're always way in
favor of grinding permission but that
way you know in
areas where maybe members wouldn't be so
keen will be even more difficult if
decisions such as this are referenced
because this will be a material
situation members are saying that this
explicitly said that they consider these
circumstances are sustainable if members
wish to consider that sustainable that's
in their gift but i warn you statements
such as that make very dangerous
precedent for future and for officers to
be able to resist other forms of
development so
as i said the starting point should
always be the ldp and the ldp channels
certain development into residential
elements to allocated sites and existing
segment boundaries unless material
considerations indicate otherwise
personally professionally as the
officer's report says i'm not
i'm not sure there's any material
considerations of any significant weight
but members are able to give the weight
to themselves considerations that they
see fit as they want to and that is in
their gift and just in relation to the
point about counsellor helm race in
relation to uh
live worked went so it's echoing back
in relation to working from home the
point is that you can actually live in
work from your home ancillary without it
needing planning permission
this is where i live work you need
but the point is that live work is a
totally opposite there is a significant
work element in the structure that is
sits alongside the residential which is
different to
working from home where you're in your
own world it is a thing mr lee isn't it
yeah thank you chairman thank you
councillor chandler and then i am going
to go to a vote um thank you madam
chairman um as stony hills has been
mentioned i think i spoke at every
committee against stony hills but i was
being told by officers bearing in mind
an appeal or whatever it was gone that
couldn't use the unsustainable or
anything
and i did see what happened there
um i'm trying to find it i thought there
was one relatively recently and i'm not
saying it was in maine under anywhere
but i thought there was an appeal
allowed fairly recently on some dwelling
or dwellings outside the development
boundary somewhere
i'm trying to go through the because i
tend to keep them and find it and i
couldn't find it before i came here
but have we not had any pill decision in
recent times
where a dwelling or two dwellings has
been allowed outside the development
boundary
apart from stony hills cancer apart from
stony hills mr lay
for you chairman
i off the cuff i couldn't tell you the
addresses but i can guarantee there will
have been because material
considerations will weigh in favor um
you know the point is if officers wish
to refuse a scheme outside the sermon
boundary for dwelling
normally obviously this is because of
the applicant but generally unless it's
called in the application is determined
that delegated leveling is refused if
officers wish to grant planning
permission for it we have to bring it
here because it's the batch departure
and there needs to be a natural openness
and transparency to those decisions so
that the public other people can
understand why that is going against the
ldp and hopefully that is what the
system facilitates but as i said there
will always be grinding of planning
permission contrary to policy because
the ben the material considerations were
in favor development against and that is
the
you know that i suppose to be honest the
if you were to go back a couple years
the most obvious one would be um
the bounce on blank the retirement
community outside of burnham you know
yes but that's what you know but talk
about that
as an example yes they are planning
permission granted outside the cement
boundary but it's about benefits and um
and as i said it's up to members to
weigh
those material considerations in their
own way in their own
informed judgment they're taking into
account the planning merits of the
scheme but obviously if
the statements and the level the weight
that he's given will become a standard
and will be looked at again thank you
chairman thank you very much right i
believe we had a proposal from
councillor helm to go against the
officer's recommendation do i have a
seconder for that chairman you need the
reason for approval before a second a
reason for a reason for approval counsel
is to study the ball um
if members agree to grant perhaps should
be delegated to officers subject to the
yeah
my understanding is that the applicant
has said that he is willing to do that
so that's kind of ticks that one
do i have a seconder thought okay yep is
that counselor feel there
so um
nice good question does mr lee think um
because councillor boyce raised some con
um when he was speaking he said about
the first two could be um
answered or or
or not mitigated the other way so it
turned turned around so to speak
so
do does mr lee think that those um
reasons what cancer helmets said are
strong enough so can i just have them
repeated because
i'm a little bit concerned about those
reasons that were given if they're going
to be strong enough d chairman my
understanding is that
council helm considers the site as a
sustainable location
and that as it can't be clearly seen
from the public footpath because of
screening there will be no harm
so what policy is that h what for oh
it's not that they wouldn't it they're
not conscious policy they're just saying
that they're
right
through you chairman
obviously with reasons refusal you have
to give the policies reasons for
approval don't because
there is no conflict because obviously
the reason future you're highlighting
the conflicts the reason for approval
the point is there is a silence on that
conflict i just wanted it to be really
really clear thank you yeah yeah my
understanding is yeah we don't have to
counsel schemes just very briefly i just
want to raise the issue to everybody of
the president we could set here today
thank you thank you
so we have a proposal to go against
officer recommendations and to approve
this application so bernie can we take a
vote please
yes chairman
do we have a recorded vote please i
think we
sorry can i just be clear exactly on
those reasons again the wording for the
approval
chairman sorry there was also a second
point to cancel the stamps that i didn't
answer i've just realized so i can do
that for councillor chana if she
is that the site
is in a sustainable location
and that as
the proposed dwelling
cannot be seen from the cannot be cannot
be clearly seen from the
public footpath or the footpath because
of
screening there is no harm to the
character of the area
um thank you
in relation to council stamps point
about robustness
i would say that they go very much
against many appeals we've won and
decisions um
and sorry council
staples confirm how far the site is from
the made-up footpath
roughly
but obviously you know making a decision
that says that
walking along an unlit footpath is a
sustainable location
um
i would just highl for this sort of
distance i think would be a dangerous
preston that's all i would like to say
to members gentlemen can we have the
distance before we continue the debate
chairman it's um 350 meters from the
maid part of nipsl's chase
very roughly a thousand foot
thank you
i don't know i could turn all the lights
off at midnight anyway don't they across
the district so it doesn't matter where
you are you can't see where you're going
actually
members we're about to go to a vote so
berna if you could take the uh
through you chairman can i just get some
clarification from mr lee regarding the
legal agreement as part of that
chairman
the application should be uh
mind you should be committed to be
minded grant permission subject and
delegate the decision subject to the
completion of a
predominantly for rams mitigation
because there are a couple of options
but yeah so that's it would be delegated
to officers
okay
thank you very much thank you
members we're going to take a recorded
vote and we're voting for councillor
ham's proposal to approve the
application contrary to the officer's
recommendation
and i will call your names in
alphabetical order starting with
councillor beale
abstain
cancer helm
cancer
schemes
against
cancer stamp
full
thank you members carried i believe
that's four yes four or five for the
application one against and two
abstentions so that's carried so um the
application is approved contrary to
officer recommendation thank you members
he's done but not necessarily conditions
yeah if if the conditions be delegated
to officers agreement with yourself
consultation with yourself yeah
delegated to officers counselor boys
members and that brings us on to item
six any other items business that the
chairman decides urgent i have none
so thank you very much
oh
there's been a couple of appeal
decisions lately
one was plant pack about a fence
it was turned down by officers but one
on appeal
and then we approved the barn at mayland
but that was turned down by an appeal
decision
and costs weren't awarded
so we passed something that was waiting
for appeal which i did mention at the
meeting
and they would have turned it down but
we approved it
mr lee
chairman but for instance if they are
the two appeal decisions i'm thinking of
actually i'm fairly familiar with them
in relation to the fencing at the
industrial unit originally the applicant
had suggested a
a hedging in front of the fence but
where this area is red was on the
boundary with the fence there was
actually no space in front of the fence
to actually put in a hedging during the
appeal process the applicant changed it
to actually being uh climbing
plants up the hedge so the mitigation
changed and therefore the reason the
concerns that with that and in relation
to the other point is this the uh minaj
yeah the menage was about a lawful
development certificate which the
council refused because it didn't
consider it incidental the inspector
agreed with that and therefore it needed
planning permission it was therefore a
requirement for the council to determine
the application so
both of both things actually
officers are quite happy with the
outcomes because that is what we were
trying to see mitigation and also that
we didn't think that a menage was
incidental and that's what the inspector
agreed with there's obviously a big
difference between a lawful development
certificate and granting planning
permission
thank you very much for clarifying that
thank you very much for clarifying that
mr lee that was very helpful
members
i now draw the meeting to a close at
8 29 pm
thank you and good night